the question of what I was doing when I
got the Nobel Prize call a question that
has been asked a thousand times I think
many people have listened to the call
that was recorded and which I didn't
know and put on the website and I was
driving in the middle of Spain trying to
find a small city where we're supposed
to go for conference most people who
live in the United States if they have
the fortune or luck or both to get such
a call most people are sleeping except
if they expected and the usual procedure
is as I understand is that you first get
the call and then you're called again
and we call in his only done for the
when time you call it again so most
people are prepared they know what
they're going to do and my cold Oviatt
already had shower when they got the
call so the situation was a little
different for me because the first Corps
never reached me Adam Smith who was part
of Nova media I understand was actually
the one who called me and my first
thought was quite honestly skeptic
skepticism I was skeptic about the call
I felt that there was something not
quite it didn't sound like that somebody
was a high English accent would call you
about that so I was a little cautious i
was also a little sleepy because i
hadn't slept the night before of course
was flying and so
I had to gather my wits and try to
figure out whether that was actually a
truthful call or prank